okay well it's very important that we
have an open dialogue about the future
of migrants in Europe and so today we
want to provide a space for cities
regions and rural areas and I come from
a rural area it's very important in
English out west England to exchange
ideas constructively about the
integration of migrants into communities
throughout Europe citizen regions are
key to welcoming and integrating
migrants and it's important that they
should be able to access resources from
the EU so our conference will be both
practical and it'll give information on
resources it'll tell you about funding
as well as giving you information and
giving you knowledge on how to do the
best you can for the migrants that we
will welcome into our region we will be
exchanging ideas and best practice that
a lot of you are already implementing
many of you have got experience of them
in your own area and we would love to
learn from you some ideas that can be
passed across Europe so as you see we're
in for a very busy day I have a slight
amount of experience because I come from
a small village called up climb which
has 1,000 inhabitants we are about to
welcome a Syrian family of four into our
region we have to pay nine thousand
pounds ten thousand euros which we are
at the moment raising we also have to
find accommodation for the Syrian family
and we have to work out their dentists
their doctors their schooling their
shops their cooking how they get around
their language problems so this is very
much like home and I'm sure that I will
learn a lot from you
today for our village as well right so
now after all this ramble it's time we
got cracking on the conference and we
start in the capable hands of both the
European Commission and then the
committee of the regions so we're going
to welcome firstly a brand new
Commissioner for Home Affairs mrs viva
johansson and after that karl-heinz
Lambert's President of the European
Committee of the regions both of them
have to go sadly after the conference
because they're working very hard after
they have spoken so firstly it will it
gives me great pleasure now to welcome
Commissioner viva johansson head of the
Home Affairs Division of the European
Commission to open our conference mrs.
Johansson has just taken on this new
office since two days and she's been a
member of the Swedish irate start since
2006 her previous posts in the Swedish
government have included Minister for
employment and integration minister for
schools Minister for welfare and elderly
health care so you can see that mrs.
Johansson is in a perfect position to
know about all the aspects of
integration of migrants we look forward
very much to hearing you
Viva Johansson
[Applause]
thank you good morning it's a pleasure
to be here with you on my second day in
office and to be part of this opening of
this conference I would just start to
say something about my portfolio and
then I was is something about my
experience from working quite intense
with integration from the country I come
from I'm now they're responsible for
security and migration
that's quite a huge portfolio and in my
aspect there are some are connections
between the two areas my portfolio but
they're also some important differences
when it comes to security I think that
it's about cohesion in society security
is about protecting our citizens from
being victims of crimes and I think it's
important for cohesion that ordinary
citizens feel that they are protected by
society those are the very rich then can
buy their own security they can move to
the source safer areas they can buy
surveillance or whatever but ordinary
citizens has to rely on society on
police force on Intelligence I think
it's important that we can show that we
can protect people from being victims of
crimes and crimes are not only punishing
the victims that are the victim of a
specific crime it's also like a poison
in society so when you have the feeling
that this society is not secure enough I
am NOT protected it's like a poison that
destroys cohesion in society so for me
security is about cohesion and how we
can build a strong society where people
feel they are part of it basically it
creates Society of cohesion and when
they are equally treated and equally
protected migration
has been over ten in ten will have a lot
of tensions during the last year's in
the European Union but I think that it's
time now to have a little bit cooler way
of talking about migration we should not
have that very very high voices or a
very very political sharp argument I
think it's time to be more pragmatic and
practical about migration every year
between 2 million and two and a half
million people from third countries come
to live in European Union some for a
short while but most of them will stay
for long probably longer than expected
from the first and they these are the
big thing in migration but we tend to
talk very much about about 100,000
people that arrive irregularly through
the Mediterranean and through the the
eastern armed borders but most of the
people that come here as migrants are
these two and a two and a half million
people I think it's important to have
this this in mind I have got Olaf on the
line has even mean the task to find a
fresh start and a new pact on migration
and asylum and that of course gonna be
quite a difficult task to unblock the
blocked situation especially among
between member states and I started
yesterday to meet with all the ministers
in the council and I'm gonna travel to
meet bilaterally with all the Member
States to find out where a new
compromise can be found but it was a
quite positive impression I had
yesterday from the member state I think
there is a momentum and I think
everybody realized that we have to come
forward with a common approach and a
common compromise because we are paying
quite a high price every week that we do
not come forward with a common policy on
migration and the side
both when it comes to the trust and
cohesion between Member States but of
course for the migrants themselves they
are being stucked in very difficult and
dangerous circumstances as long as we do
not have this compromise in place so
this going to be one of my priorities I
think of course I don't know the outcome
of the dialogues yet but I do think that
we need to protect our borders our
external borders better than we have
done and I do think that we have to be
much more efficient on returns we have
to make a distinct distinction between
those that are eligible for
international protection or for other
reasons have the right to stay in
European Union and those that have not
and I think this is what the citizens
were asked us from the European level to
deliver our the distinction between
those that should be welcome and those
that actually have to leave another
important part is to find better and
more legal pathways to Europe so people
do not need to come through irregular
ways risking their lives there should be
more legal path weights to come and help
to contribute to the European economy
and also to come as a refugees through
resettlement I think these are better
ways to also welcoming people in the
European Union and we have also to fight
there the migrants smugglers that are
actually risking people's lives every
day and they're earning a lot of money
on doing so third I think it's very
important that those that are eligible
to stay in Europe we have to be very
clear you are welcome I'm happy to have
you here I want you to succeed in your
new home country I want you to be part
of the labour market
I want your children to succeed in
school I want you to be part of our
local community and this is about
integration and also about faith
fighting racism and discrimination and
this is what this conference is about
I wish you all success with your very
important tasks on integration on this
conference integration in my our
perspective is always local sometimes
you have been almost how long time will
it take to become a Swedish citizens the
answer is seven years then you can
become a Swedish citizens but how long
time will it take before you're part of
a local community
three generations maybe something like
that so it's very very we are very very
local or regional and that's very big
part of the identity for all the
inhabitants to be part of their region
or their local community and that's
where the newcomers has to be welcomed
into their new country of course but
most of all into their new local
community and that's why integration is
always local it's all about community
it's about culture it's about narrative
is about networking and of course you
can't copy from one region to another
from one member states to another
because it's local so it differs but you
can learn from each other and I think
it's very very important with the
cooperation that you are ongoing and
that we have to strengthen between
different regions in the European Union
to work together to learn from each
other both from the best practice but
also from some failures or mistakes that
we also make so I think this this is
very important of course there's a lot
of challenges when it comes to practical
things like housing schools child care
health care language courses all of that
has to be in place but I want to paint
point out also some experience and I
have I think for adults
entering the labor market is really
crucial to be part of your new country
and being integrated it's about dignity
earning your own money but it's also
about
having your profession recognized and
I've been thinking about that my
profession is I'm a teacher in math this
is what I really can do I know that I
can teach you all quite difficult or
levels of math because that's my
profession if I were a newcomer in a new
country where I didn't know anything I
would like to start with something I
know something a place or a platform
where I feel confident but I don't want
to be to feel stupid there's a lot of
new things I have to learn the language
the curricula the culture you know
everything but it should be nice to
start with something where I feel
confident I have some profession and
that's why I think it's important to
recognize their professional background
for people coming to the new country and
of course there are differences and all
that but I think this is could be a
starting point and also to use social
partners or in other means finding
mentors from the same kind of profession
to help integrate into the new to the
working life I will share with you an
experience I had I visited a very small
local community in the north of Sweden
where there are a lot of migrants coming
from Syria mainly and they have started
they needed the workforce in the local
manufacturing industry but there was a
problem with the language of course so
they set up a specific language course
special for this local industry and they
could start working only after a few
months in Sweden and when I went there I
talked to them and they spoke very well
Swedish I was so surprised because you
know they were standing there they
weren't quite alone with the machines
and robots or things like that and how
have you practice all the language when
did you learn
that's which language well you know we
have very good office parties for their
all their employees at this workplace
and then we have a beer or a glass of
wine and then we start talking so this
is also about we are human beings and we
integrate to each other in at the
workplace but also for for social
reasons language is of course important
and I just want to say that I think it's
important to gather people of course for
our learning the new language but also
to communicate without language that can
sometimes be also of have this feeling
you're not stupid you can't communicate
and then you can learn a language how do
you communicate without a proper
language it's by using music singing
playing music it's by sports it's
playing chess it's by gathering around
your small children a lot of these
things that you can communicate to each
other without having so many words and
that's also a way of developing the
language that was just a small example I
know you have many more to share with
each other and I hope you will be
successful on this are during this
conference and I think that successful
integration must be a very important
part of a new packet on migration and
asylum and we need this whole of society
approach to integration we're all
stakeholders are involved and at the
local and the regional level that's
where you have the stakeholders that are
relevant for a successful integration
European funding plays an essential role
to support the work of integration at a
local level as you all are aware of
between 2015 in 2018 under the asylum
migration integration fund about 5
million people have benefited from
integrating integrations
and that's why we the Commission have
proposed that for the next multi-annual
financial framework but we should
provide significantly more financial
resources for integration that we have
had there during the current period
firstly the Commission has proposed to
triple the amount of marker money for
the asylum and migration fund
secondly integration will become a
priority also for the future European
Social Fund plus and for the European
Regional Development Fund to be
complement intervention by the asylum
and migration fund therefore overall a
much larger larger amount of money from
EU budget will be available to finance
integration measure and I think this is
necessary because as you all know
sometimes it could also be difficult
especially for small local communities
to get access to the EU funds that's why
the Commission has proposed several new
elements to make funding for integration
more accessible for local authorities
and today I'm happy to announce the
award of 13 million euros of emergency
funding to Italy and Spain to improve
social cohesion in local communities
that have recently received a
significant number of people in Italy
about 10 million euros or more funding
will support the project local
government network for rapid response of
fast-track inclusion services in
disadvantaged urban areas this funding
will support migrant communities facing
precarious situation in 18 Italy and
municipalities by supporting local civic
engagement project housing Inclusion
measures and emergency services such as
access to medical of psychosocial care
and
basic assistance services in Spain over
three million of funding will support
amigo in response to the immigration
situation in the south of Spain amigo
2019 these funds will go towards
reinforcing the cap capacities of the
civil guard or the Spanish Minister of
Interior to organize
external border and coastal surveillance
and providing basic assistance to
migrants ladies and gentleman's friends
and active people are on the local and
regional level you are one of the most
potent four important stakeholders for a
functioning and successful integration I
wish you all good luck for your
conference and thank you for this
opportunity
thank you very much indeed commissioner
you're handsome for such a rousing
beginning and such a welcoming field for
everybody I was very interested to hear
that one could communicate without
language through music sport and chess
that is a very good beginning indeed
very thank you so much and I wish you
well in your new job which is a very
nice change from teaching maths now we
have the pleasure of hearing from the
president of the committee of the
regions
karl-heinz Lambeth he'll be speaking
French about Pat Lyon France al
observable is interpreter here you have
your interpreters behind mr. Lamberg has
a background in law he became president
in 2017 and he's been a member of the
committee of the regions the COR since
2001 after serving a two and a half year
term as first vice president we are
looking forward very much to hearing
Commissioner lumber or silver Joey Abbas
entendre Monsieur l'ambassadeur Michel
Michel Madame Monsieur Reserve exactly
Ramon to visit confer us kisses $3 card
SF are also 300 ma pala Commission
European in La cometa European region
Pahlavi olive on contra de Villa de
region in the suit near dollar of action
data Graziano
Demi grown in the refugee in civilian
purity absolute polluters in a presence
telenovela myself madam L Johansen
illustrates a vehicle Poirot Nobel
Committee on VPN per set upon Rosetta
Matic a curve aspetta new servo location
on solar vector Commission donde la
yaani a venir da matta near Liz Angus
Moore OTT pre dollar posse not a Mopar
preserved Madame Johansen
eco-silver de Luci dollar estate
occasion Rosario goes more ownership Oh
Sun sutiya Oh de la de la vaca Nissan's
vivo report on kuzu blame fl0 Grigio
novo facility la processes that de
Gracia Torres own rival la conférence
des jeux de da news idea conspiracy
screw positives of La Migra song reverbs
Abbate salud after the seventh year it's
all a solidarity L do a continuous
alifair you some concern kill Sally
Laden low the responsibility
gusano C converted ensemble new genres
real affair with a rope lady of avail
the finest modality Graziano in the
sutra direct oval region a new srivalli
negotiation isn't inclusivity of carve a
final see a priori annual affair dossier
earlier entre la cosa economic a
territorial ill inclusive social even am
la camisa entire vehicle
zalazala debe key oddity tres optimist
is a special reconcilable para la riva
Montessori the des idees the mountain
country we are no news of York organ is
in conference consecration area
Universal antique Rizzo Dimitra I be
refugee support Maria initiative ville
de mr. DeMille a direction general home
tour Ricardo de Papua
singie on do mill self-supporting area
acclaimed dynamic in cooperation it is a
short constitutive concern ala
politically here at the Gracia in a
committee
oh yeah EF de travail a alize ensemble
poor complete Erie's action depart Anaya
Yoruba not recommittal hace una vida y
initiative villi region polenta Gracie
on kiddo no petite Vil eurozone viva la
possibility de soleil eagle more days
affirmation a solid short movie to a
sustainable problem so Lanza Permira
Creon espacio communique de manera
constant ypsilanti gracio a pooh-bah
tierra de screw positive a father de
construir less stereotypical east chief
release o CJ de lama gracie own deputies
municipality level time lion arizona
evil so sue present in Arezzo exist oh
no sue von para possibility de cobre Le
Bon Appetit experience existent say
Poconos own Cuba's Raul Akuma soul open
a nosy dial sued near Carlotta Crisanta
defeat comedy console Oh silly situation
Oh de la de periphery
oh man lavon's Fox amor de la
coopération y la conexión on television
metro region metropolitan debited will
the municipality satorious unravel per
contributor deafening unapproachable por
la política de gracia a quad as healer
difficulty Isuzu some vodka travel
Eurasian issue that was a tomorrow of a
delay not initiative pulper otaku
sedessa a success a remarkable miss
episode curve upon final on Verona mati
Dontrelle saw that petit will the
control populace the second millimeter
in a tone the valley shows Suzanne
O'Donnell the deferred integrity on over
an affair a couch
Rupali on the possibility diverse
democracy dollar Capitolina in losery
obiagu marla Bertier associative OPM
Priscilla dairy Prezi key table you know
some to Trapasso la ba la camisa open
participant repository Deborah
ba-da-da-da-da Sonali nos espera Tuvok
continued a beneficial Sun so theodora's
Ani Avni savage la cabeza la palabra
pakal's Nouveau Mona hostile vo cuticle
nosy for Conran de muchacho de resolute
account rep Oh No consider a tyranny see
who our new prevailed organization Siri
Devin McCann's Ron o Kudrin a portion
Sheila temple la lutte contre DISA
formación de strategy Dante Graziano
reveal a region Parma no principal
partner figure eagle mall is Association
territorial European tell callosum
literary genre rural cities reconcile
the community journal Europe will call a
conference that is not peripheric emery
team here to trip on d+ more an acapella
y'know if a king partisan mm subjective
element on Jean de prueba platform doll
ensemble in European so they'll set
initiative no properly buried to support
its potential
Madame Monsieur Gustave on column it
wobbles Landro to solidarity mustafa
aashiq europe abbas Rondo the Poconos
immobilized in community the responsible
politic concern defect to the develop
more territorial drug hip who possess
your lack Rouge on a key supply already
found Jenny Japan's cassette conference
Palooza prendre boku no Shoals
dasa domain account really arid areas
under set objective the session thematic
is the rule womp RL 2
to Andales Rooney who permit rendezvous
processor different thematic Delano
al analyzed adorn a opossum Paris pour
les Horizonte low-voltage antenna
strategy local Dante Graziano Metro
Eagle mall axilla communication eerily
Toronto ladies información seek asylum
on yard or disaster mafiosi anova home
Valenti grassy own attorney case
Elsevier a suit - on c-- news avanza
golmal organizations the Castillo
reports effect is expel the different
form
- ours de Velde initiative alpha y sub 2
general kavagi totally collectivity
locally regional president Audrey Adair
a anak initiative Villa de hablar de
gracia packages massage avec la razón
vous pouvez no Corrado soprano of War II
saw a questionnaire miserable a
disposition general similarity love the
pose of the difference SEO avoided in
the photography expositors it's all a
lot ET please Oh Patrick Wanda reverb
but the person isn't irresolute ignacio
ET au choix ZDX premier circles concept
signify to l.a cote de la musique la
photography to see along gosh bonita
sell cattle mortal
compound whose only Lucilla Cassandra
dear
lock eldest a photography cover smaller
please a votre papa with jean de lat
Agassi on Madame Monsieur driven
straight in journey Fructis fructose is
revoir merci de batata sir
[Applause]